you realize how hot it is outside
you know the vehicle off windows up you
got tape around your dog's mouth
shocking video shows the disturbing
aftermath of a three-month-old puppy
locked inside a hot vehicle
with a lot of saliva
maybe like he wasn't able to breathe the
las vegas metropolitan police department
released body camera footage of the july
20th incident when they say 50 year old
rahul cabal hall left his puppy inside
the vehicle for nearly two hours as he
went inside to gamble you have a husky
inside the vehicle
it happened on the top floor of the
bellagio parking garage employees there
rescued the dog through the vehicle's
sunroof
where's the dog
when recovering the animal workers found
tape covering its mouth are you the
owner of this vehicle
the mercedes yes all right
put your hands behind your back
palms together almost together las vegas
officials say the high temperatures that
day reached
113 degrees going to jail on a felony
willful
endangerment of an animal
carbajal was arrested for willful
malicious torture of an animal for the
latest developments in this story and
all things true crime stay with long
crime network i'm sierra gillespie